this last spring I was commissioned an
essay by Bishop Barron's word on fire
journal which comes out quarterly and
they were putting out an issue on faith
and film so they asked me to write an
essay for it I asked him if I could read
the essay for you and they said that it
would be fine and so I'm going to read
this essay because I think I was really
able to concisely put together my vision
of how culture can be healed or how we
can integrate healthy culture and as we
just saw in the last few weeks we saw
Jordan Peterson reappear we were happy
to see that he is seems to be doing a
little better and so it's also an
opportunity for me to frame my
relationship with him in terms of
thought what are the similarities and
especially what are the differences that
separate Jordan and I in our perception
of how to engage to heal to deal with a
difficulty in modern culture
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
the world is suddenly keen on
storytelling after a few decades of the
new atheist assault of the postmodern
undermining and fragmentation of
identities of the venomous insistence
that all that makes us human is a social
construct as opposed to the objectivity
of the scientists a strange post
atheistic professor from Toronto has
shaken the core of secularists discourse
of course there are those Bishop Baron
among them who have been hacking at the
question of narrative for a while but as
I stood there at a Toronto bus station
late one evening in the fall of 2016 I
knew that the moment and the character I
was facing were different after a
goodbye hug and a pause I looked at
Jordan Peterson and said you're gonna
bring back Christianity his surprised
reaction betrayed hesitation followed by
his secular alternative hopefully we can
get people to understand the
psychological significance of these
Bible stories I was unsettled by his
answer and it still rings in my ear to
this day and now four years later in the
wake of Jordan Peterson's rise to
worldwide fame and after a bewildering
cascade of YouTube videos interviews
lectures debates and a surprising
tectonic shift in the discourse about
religion
it seems the issue is still playing out
which one of the two options Jordans
prediction or mine will come out on top
of course a return to Christianity and
the discovery of the deep profundity of
its stories are not exclusive to each
other any thoughtful Christian knows of
the psychological Keys offered up in the
Bible yet to communicate the relevance
of our faith it is incumbent on us to
celebrate not only the psychological
depths of Scripture but also its cosmic
and metaphysical fullness we should not
only remember and reinterpret the
ancient narrative but lead our former
detractors by the hand
grand anse of our liturgy our art our
architecture and our pious legends it
has been given to us to show the world
how all these modern stories these
novels we read and these movies we watch
are useful but the most powerful stories
are those we live and participate in
surprisingly facing the current social
breakdown of meaning and identity in the
West the Christian story presents itself
once again as the only viable solution
to the widening gyre the only meta
narrative that makes sense of it all
Christians should not underestimate the
power of our story and the liberation it
provides in the midst of a rising
nihilism while modern scientists and
philosophers are wrestling with
questions of complexity and emergence
meaning is reappearing as imperative for
the world's existence and meaning making
no longer appears as a superstitious man
oh we can discard mind essence and logos
but also in turn incarnation of
principles like story body and image all
shine in our strange historical moment
as the very keys to how reality unfolds
but before we take on the mysteries of
the cosmos the Christian story first has
the power to liberate the body of Christ
from the yoke of so-called critical
scholarship what I call story and what
our ancestors called tradition is this
golden thread of narrative people
intention and spirit that can free us
from the scholars autopsy of Scripture
which has culminated into the sterile
Jesus Seminar and celebrity atheist
Bible scholars let us remember and
celebrate the story of Christ not the
story limited to Christ's red letter
statements and to the burden of
scholarly approval but rather the story
that animated the medieval Mystery Plays
the one that spans from the first word
of creation to humankind made in the
image the fall the covenants the law the
carnation the death and resurrection the
ascension into heaven the sitting on the
right hand of the Father and the coming
again in glory to judge the living and
the dead that story is the culmination
and condensation of all storytelling
firstly because it is the meta story it
is about how meaning logos is the source
of reality and how it fills doubts and
questions with a full yet adapted answer
it is the ultimate story because it
manifests the most pristine example of
descent and ascent the universal
u-shaped story described to us by modern
scholars from Frazer to Northrop Frye
the u-shaped structure is found in the
story of Jesus Christ through death and
resurrection but is ultimately a cosmic
story spanning from the garden and the
fall to the holy city Christ as the
personal embodiment of the cosmic story
also blends together all the aspects of
the human archetype he is the type of
all story characters for each presented
as priest as king as warrior as artisan
as servant as pastor as gardener both
solar and Reaper as prophet as teacher
as healer as virgin as bridegroom as
judge as victim as outcast as criminal
as scandal as descending to the lowest
rung of hell and ascending to the right
hand of the Father he is the Creator who
becomes the creature he is Adam who
allows himself to be overwhelmed by the
serpent for our sake he is life that
becomes death light that becomes
darkness alpha to Omega all in order to
saturate the entire cosmos and
meta-narrative with the fullness of its
origin and to change even death into
glory to recover the ancient story we
must first recover its scope in recent
decades we have seen Christians attempt
to connect to a secular world that has
progressed
we broken from their embrace popular
culture since the Renaissance has grown
from neutrally secular to openly hostile
against Christianity as rebellion
individualism and the dismantling of
authority had become the main tropes of
both the subject and forms of culture
and everything from avant-garde art to
rock and roll we have seen Christians
running up to catch up with secular
culture our efforts are usually mediocre
in the empty quest for innovation and
individual creativity the last century
has left us with a wasteland of bad
church architecture bad liturgical art
bad music but also a slew of humdrum
attempts from Christians to make secular
art as well but as the explicitly
Christian iconography and narrative
recede from the public space their
implicit structures begin to emanate in
a strange dim glow which appears
stronger as the main light fades and so
it is as Christianity is set aside we
can never nevertheless see the story of
the resurrection everywhere in popular
culture the knock down hero getting up
at the last moment has become such a
standard pattern of popular movies and
fiction that we fail to recognize what
it owes to the synthesis of that pattern
in the story of Christ watching rocky or
Thor or neo get beaten down for several
minutes until it becomes unbearable only
to see the hero rise in victory at the
end has become a permanent pattern of
storytelling even beyond the acts of a
protagonist when imposes itself in the
modern hero is a Christian Knight who
sacrifices himself to help the weak and
the helpless the heroes and gods of old
like Hercules or Achilles like Odin and
Thor acted out of a desire to obtain
riches and glory to defend their own
clans or at best to acquire wisdom for
themselves although there are some hints
or pre figurations of self-sacrifice in
antiquity the death of Socrates
be seen through that angle it is truly
in Christ that this trope becomes the
narrative pattern for our modern heroes
in the conclusion of Marvel's Avengers
epic the series finds its climax in the
moment where Tony Stark's succeeds in
using the power of the Infinity Gauntlet
the weapon wielded by Thanos in order to
turn it against Thanos and thereby annul
the power of death we had seen this
moment before in modern narrative the
power of the gauntlet is the power of
the One Ring in tokine's epoch forged by
the evil Lord Sauron the ring holds
untold power in the Lord of the Rings
several important characters are tempted
to use its power for good
yet we discover how the absolute power
of the Ring would corrupt the user and
turn them into the very tyrant they wish
to oppose why then is it different for
Tony Stark to take the gauntlet from
Thanos what narrative change may the
Avengers climax so successful the answer
is a Christian one it is because the act
of wielding this absolute power was also
an act of self-sacrifice it is because
Tony Stark consented to die so that he
could defeat death by death the story of
Tony Stark a selfish arrogant
billionaire reaching the end of his
narrative arc by sacrificing himself to
save mankind is a story that is
impossible without Christ the story of
Christ is everywhere it fills our novels
our movies our comic books and TV shows
it fills our political and family
narratives and it even frames our self
perception a worldview without Christ is
one that can barely be imagined anymore
only maybe in the guise of its inversion
the antihero and Antichrist who cannot
help despite himself to point at what is
inverted although it may seem like an
aporia to some
and it's very eraser from the common
discourse even as it is being shooed
from the public sphere we can see how
the story of Christ will inevitably
return in its fullness I say this not as
a vague prophecy or a sentimental desire
but rather as the inevitable playing out
of a pattern as common as the waning and
waxing of the moon of the moon or the
setting and rising of the Sun the
meta-narrative embodied in the
crucifixion will also play itself out in
the story of Christianity as the cosmic
body of Christ Christ reaches the
resolution of its own story in February
of this year the film director and
universal geek Kevin Smith tweeted out
something fascinating religions quote
religions have been founded on the Bible
resulted in millions of people deriving
inspiration and moral strength from
amazing stories about fantastic feats of
faith hundreds of years from now our
descendants will find divine inspiration
from the story of CAP wielding Mjolnir
and quote he was referring to a scene in
Avengers endgame where Captain America
picks up Thor's hammer and uses it to
fight with Thanos something which is
supposed to happen only in the hands of
a God worthy of the weapon the tweet
exposes many things simultaneously first
it shines a light on how there is an
explicit attempt in recent large-scale
movies to use highly
mytho religious language in their
storytelling second it suggests these
stories are on par with the ancient ones
and are set to replace them for someone
in the comic book and movie industry to
proclaim this so explicitly something
that had been a nebulous speculation on
the part of us watching culture
simultaneously exposes the shallowness
and impossibility of such a proposition
it is one thing to see the analogy
between these entertainment ventures and
the stories that really matter it is
another to declare the Disney
comic book characters will replace
religion may seem that I'm snubbing my
nose at popular entertainment but that's
not the point
the problem with the superhero movie is
not in its capacity to embody or not the
cosmic patterns it is in how there
exists a fundamental difference between
entertainment and active life the story
of Christ and even the ancient myths
were not just stories people told to
entertain each other to make people
think or even to inspire action
certainly these ancient stories could do
all of that but mostly the ancient
stories were our stories the stories of
who we are why we are here where we are
going the story of Christ is what we are
meant to enter into to be baptized into
Christ to put on Christ to become the
image of Christ the communion of the
saint and the tradition of the Apostles
are an actual thread of people and
stories that link us to Christ and to
our ancestors their stories are our
stories we're not we not only speak them
but celebrate them not on not naming our
cities and our children after these
people the Saints are present to us we
ask them to pray for us and with them we
celebrate and worship Christ and whose
story we are all called to be glorified
and so when we point to the new stories
and enjoy how they embody some aspect of
the great pattern how they embody this
or that aspect of Christ everything
flows in the right direction but when
the opposite happens and we suggest that
these new stories could act as a
replacement for the Christian story then
all the superficial qualities of these
new stories come to the fore and they
appear as empty vessels none of us can
live in the trademark and copyrighted
Marvel Universe even if Disney builds a
theme park for us none of us can point
to the place where Ironman was martyred
or display the hammer picked up by
Captain
erricka in the famous battle of endgame
these fictional stories are only liminal
their power on us can only awaken a
desire to live in our own story but the
story of Christ and His Saints a very
cosmic story from creation to the
eschaton is the one in which we live
every day it is the story that we
celebrate during our liturgies that
marks our space through sacred sites
that marks our year with feasts and
processions the secular world has tried
to replace all of this but its efforts
only feed the fragmentation and leveling
tendency of modernity and so we all
Teeter on the shore of deep nihilism as
the waves get higher and the storm comes
closer finally we should not take
lightly the powerful shift in culture
that has taken place since the
then-unknown professor in Toronto spoke
out against mandatory speech
requirements yet in the wake of the
quote Jordan Peterson movement as I pray
for the health and recovery of my friend
I feel it is nonetheless my role to say
we must reach further it is not enough
to understand stories psychologically
and it is not enough to be upstanding
individuals it is not enough to live by
stories we must live in them the stories
must be a path we walk part of the glue
that holds us together and individuals
must unite themselves to a body
well-formed in love so that we grow up
into the logos himself who is the head
without that extra step we will
ultimately be dispersed like smoke like
wax before the fire